Hey guys,
Tim Ferriss here.
I'm going to show you just a few exercises that I found very helpful for hip and
ankle mobility or flexibility because these have been too weak points of mine
for a very long time.
I've had a lot of injuries both in the hips and in the ankles.
My,
my dorsiflex action on the left is terrible compared to the right.
So I'll show you what I mean.
If I have checked this out,
my toes on the same line.
Okay.
And I pushed my knees forward.
You can see that my right knee is probably a good three to four inches ahead of
my left and the left feels bone on bone a lot of the time.
But I'll show you three things that have helped with that end with improving
what you might call grumpy baby.
Uh,
I've never been able to do happy baby and yoga,
which is effectively what I just showed you.
So working on that has been extremely important for a number of sports.
I'm working on an acrobatics and acro yoga.
So what to do.
And these were both things that resisted many different attempts previously.
So the first thing I'm going to show you is from coach,
summer of gymnastic bodies,
former national team coach for men's gymnastics.
And that is effectively on,
and there are many different ways to go about this.
But first,
let's just say you did 60 calf raises,
okay?
And candidate off and then went down into a position like this and I'll give you
a diagonal can't,
I'm not going to be doing this perfectly.
You notice that this is kind of out to the side to take out the hip flexor.
Uh,
and then I'm just stretching the Kellys and calf here.
All right?
And then I would hold this for 60 to 120 seconds.
You should all check out his programming because it's much more sophisticated
and this is from him,
but that is exercise one.
You'd do it on both sides.
Next I'm going to give the ankles a bit of a break and work on the grumpy baby
to happy baby transition.
And this is very simple.
I'm going to be in this type of staggered position.
Okay?
My hips are square,
so not rotating like this or rotating this way.
I'm not in a warrior pose of anytime in my toes are pointing straight ahead.
And uh,
this is very similar to what you might've seen from say a verse Dagon,
uh,
or Eric Cressey does a lot of great work with this type of thing.
Uh,
I'm just going to drop the elbow
and then keeping this like in up whole with my back to get a lot of rotation and
just do this perhaps six times going to max depth for a very short half,
second or second.
Notice that if one is reasonably easy to do,
I'm going to inch that foot forward.
And then you would repeat on the opposite side.
Same Story.
All right and down.
And then
just like that,
not spending a lot of time in these positions,
that's how you end up really,
really sore.
Oftentimes if you are spending a lot of time in those positions,
again refer to coach summer on this,
you're not going to be doing intensive long holds all the time.
You might be doing it once a week,
twice a week.
That's it.
Alright.
So the next move,
that'd be one,
two and covered the Achilles stretch after and gorging the area with blood.
We talked about the,
these sort of grumpy baby happy baby and this one is a caustic squat so nothing
has helped my ankle,
dorsiflexion Dorsey flection pulling the foot back,
right that range of motion as much as Cossack squats.
And these were really introduced to me by Pavel Tsatsouline who is very well
known for popularizing kettlebells in the u s among other things.
And uh,
you can do this without weights and you should first,
the key element or one of the key elements for the,
the goals that we have that I discussed
is you want to keep your hips as low as possible as you move from one side to
the other.
Now you can do them with your foot like,
so this is going to use the adductors more or you can,
you can flip this one out and get more hamstring.
I tend to do it this way.
And then from here you would just glide across.
I have a lot of trouble keeping my hips low to here.
I can already see that this ankle is more restricted,
I find because of that restriction,
it's counterintuitively perhaps easier when you have some weight to load with
and that is true with pistols.
Oftentimes one legged squats.
Okay,
so if I'm here and get this up just to kind of a goblet hold.
Okay.
Like so I tend to put it right under the Chin and then
just coming across like this and I'll spend a little bit of time just working on
each side.
A few seconds.
Do that six times or so,
dropped the kettle bell,
come on up,
relax.
And that's about it.
The consistency is more important than the intensity or the volume.
And for more on that for more than stretching or highly recommend coach,
summer s o m m e r Pavel,
Tsatsouline relaxing to stretch.
But as far as starter kits go,
there are three that I found very,
very helpful.
Hope you enjoyed the video.
If you would like to see my favorite piece of content that I put out every week,
it is a short newsletter,
five bullet Friday.
It's free.
It's five bullet points with the coolest things that I have been finding using
testing and a given week.
I put it out every Friday.
You can digest it in about five minutes.
Take a look.
Five bullet Friday.